President Trump is pushing back this
morning against Democratic claims that
they have a framework for a deal to save
nearly 700,000 young immigrants from
deportation the Democrats say the
potential agreement would replace daca
and that funding the border wall would
not be part of the deal but this morning
the president tweeted no deal was made
last night on daca massive border
security would have to be agreed to in
exchange for consent Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill to explain it all Nancy
good morning good morning decoding this
everyone is essentially saying the same
thing they're just using different words
essentially they did come to an
agreement last night on a framework for
how to deal with these young people it
involves taking the DREAM Act granting
them the chance to apply for legal
status and pairing it with the border
security measures that Republicans want
without the border wall funding that
Democrats hate but conservatives are
still going to see that as a betrayal
and the White House knows it White House
aides insisted last night the president
was not going back on that campaign
promise after Democratic leaders said he
had agreed to and shrine the protections
of daca into law quickly and to work out
a package of border security excluding
the wall White House press secretary
Sarah Sanders quickly shot back while
daca and border security were both
discussed excluding the wall was
certainly not agreed to
more and more were trying to work things
out together but the president made the
same promise to a bipartisan group of
lawmakers earlier in the day
Texas Democrat Henry Cuellar I think
we're all in the same page that we're
not going to tie the wall to daca what's
going on democratic sources say mr.
Trump has a soft spot for the dreamers
and liked the reaction he got for
cutting another bipartisan deal over the
debt ceiling last week conservative
Congressman Steve King tweeted if the
president is backing off the wall Trump
bases blown up destroyed irreparable and
disillusioned beyond repair no promise
is credible late last night Steve
bannon's website Breitbart called the
president amnesty Don former White House
chief strategist told
Charlie Rose that a deal on Daka would a
lien eight the president's supporters
there's no path to citizenship no path
to a green card and no innocent amnesty
is non-negotiable but President Trump
himself countered this morning does
anybody really want to throw out good
educated and accomplished young people
who have jobs some serving in the
military really aides have said before a
gale that he is okay
leaving wall funding out of this package
as long as he gets it in some other bill
all right Thank You Nancy